… Outche ! Ça pique !
Mais c'est de la moutarde !
Et ça remonte jusque dans le nez...
et dans les yeux…
Vite de l’eau…
Hum !
Ça fait du bien…
En même temps,  elle a du bouquet cette moutarde !
C’est normal… la moutarde est une plante.
On a du mal à imaginer que cette petite
fleur soit à l’origine d’une telle sensation.
Il faut mener l’enquête !
Ces photos ont été prises au printemps.
Après avoir été fécondées, les fleurs produisent
des graines amères.
Une technique astucieuse pour repousser les herbivores et les granivores.
Bon ! Il y a des petits malins
comme ce rongeur
qui vit dans le désert du Néguev en Israël.
Il se nourrit d’une cousine de la moutarde
mais il prend bien soin de recracher les graines.
Ce n’est pas à lui
qu’on vaapprendre à faire la grimace.
C’est à partir de ces graines
que l’on fabrique de la moutarde en sauce.
La récolte a lieu durant l’été.
Je vais vous montrer
à quoi elle ressemble.
Nous sommes dans
une moutarderie familiale,
l’une des dernières qui fabrique ce condiment de
manière traditionnelle. Elle a été fondée en 1840.
C’est une ancienne meule.
Et voiciles tiges de moutarde.
Elles ont bien changé
depuis le printemps.
Les graines se trouvent à l’intérieur
de ce qu’on appelledes siliques, ces petites cosses.
On dit aussi parfois
des capsules.
Allez, j’en écrase une…
C’est de la moutarde brune…
Il existe également de la moutardeblanche,
de la moutarde noire,
de la moutarde des champs,
de la moutarde sauvage…
Et le colonel Moutarde !
Pour ceux qui connaissent,
ça ressemble un petit peu aux graines de colza.
C’est normal !
Ces plantes appartiennent
à la même famille : les « brassicacées »
Auparavant on disait les crucifères,
tout simplement parce que les pétales des
fleurs sont disposés en forme de croix.
Hum ! C’est amer…
Je préfère quand ça pique…
La recette maintenant !
D’abord, il faut faire tremper les graines
dans un mélange à base de vinaigre,
d’eau et de sel, ce qu’on appelle un verjus.
Cette macération permet d’éliminer l’amertume.
C’est également à ce stade que
la moutarde devient piquante.
Au contact du verjus, les graines de moutarde
libèrent des molécules qui vont se combiner
et donner de l’essence de moutarde, de
l’isothiocyanate d’allyle pour ceux qui
ont du goût pour la chimie.
Là,
ça pique un peu.
Il a raison !
On va se contenter d’essence de moutarde.
Puis, les graines sont broyées.
Pour fabriquer 1 kg de moutarde,
il faut compter 300 grammes de graines.
Et là, ça pique !
Mais pourquoi cette sensation de picotement
remonte-t-elle dans le nez et parfois jusqu'aux yeux ?
Suivez-moi.
D’abord, le piquant n’est pas un
goût au sens strict du terme.
En effet, il existe 5 goûts différents :
amer, salé, acide, sucré et umami.
Un goût très apprécié en Asie, que nous, Occidentaux,
avons un peu de mal à décrire.
On le retrouve un petit peu
dans le lait et dans le fromage.
Quand on croque une carotte,
le sucre qu'elle contient
se lie avec les récepteurs du sucre
présents sur la langue et l’information est
transmise au cerveau
qui en déduit que la carotte est sucrée.
Souvenez-vous,
il y a quelques mois,
je vous ai expliqué pourquoi on éprouvait une sensation
de fraicheur quand on mange de la menthe.
Tout simplement parce que le menthol contenu
dans les feuilles de menthe
se lie avec lesmêmes récepteurs que ceux
sensibles aufroid. C’est un leurre en quelque sorte.
Avec la moutarde, il y a un peu de ça !
Quand on mange de la moutarde,
ses essences, les"iso quelque chose"...
se lient avec des récepteurs
spécifiques à la température.
Voilà pourquoi on a cette sensation de picotement
et aussi de chaleur. Mais ce n’est pas tout…
Les essences de moutarde sont très volatiles.
Elles se diffusent dans toute la bouche, dans les
fosses nasales, et se lient avec des récepteurs
d’un nerf particulier : le nerf trijumeau.
C'est lui qui canalise toutes les informations
recueillies par le visage jusqu’au cerveau.
Je vous ai fait un petit
schéma pour mieux comprendre.
Il se divise en 3 branches
qui innervent la bouche, le nez et les yeux.
Ce qui correspond au préfix
« tri » dans « trijumeau ».
« Jumeau » parce que chaque
branche se divise en 2.
Coté gauche et côté droit.
C’est grâce à cette implantation
que le chirurgien-dentiste peut anesthésier
un côté de la mandibule et pas l’autre.
Oh !
Bah je sens plus rien du tout...
En se diffusant, les essences de
moutarde se lient avec des récepteurs
du nerf trijumeau de toutes ces régions.
C’est pourquoi la moutarde pique le nez,
fait pleurer, alors qu’elle est posée sur la langue.
C’est aussi pour cette raison qu’il faut
bien refermer le pot de moutarde, pour
éviter que les essences ne s’échappent
et que la moutarde perde son goût.
Et maintenant un peu de géographie.
Qui dit moutarde, dit moutarde de Dijon!
Dijon et sa région.
C’est la plus connue des moutardes,
en France et dans le monde entier.
Et cette renommée ne date pas d’hier…
C’est une spécialité de la région, la Bourgogne,
depuis le Moyen Âge ! On peut dire que
dès le départ, tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour que
la sauce prenne, entre Dijon - enfin sa région -
et la moutarde : le sol est propice à la culture
de la plante et comme vous pouvez le constater,
on y cultive énormément de vignes qui donnent
un excellent vin dont utilise une petite partie
pour produire du vinaigre, un ingrédient
indispensable pour fabriquer de la moutarde.
À l’origine, il y avait même ici un cépage,
qui n’existe plus aujourd’hui, le « bourdelat»
dont on tirait un jus, le premier « verjus»,
qui a été utilisé pour faire de la moutarde.
Toujours est-il que des générations de
moutardiers vont se succéder dans la région.
Très vite, la moutarde monte sur la table du
Roi, qui nomme son propre moutardier.
Le pape en fait autant… Et il faut croire que la sauce
n’est toujours pas retombée puisqu’en 2009,
ce sont bien des pots de moutarde que
Barack Obama choisit de rapporter
de son voyage officiel en France ! À croire qu’en plus
de monter au nez, elle fait tourner les têtes…
Je reviens pour un petit bonus ! Depuis le début de
cette aventure vous êtes très nombreux à poser
des questions en commentaires des vidéos. J'ai donc
décidé d'y répondre.Alors... pas à tout, quelques-unes,
celles qui reviennent le plus souvent et aussi les
plus insolites.
Aujourd'hui, au sujet
du phénomènedes marées
Une question de Florent:
Eh bien si, il y a des marées dans la mer Méditerranée
mais ellessont beaucoup plus faibles, une quarantaine decm.
La mer Méditerranée, même si elle est très
profonde, est une mer fermée.
Et le passage qui la relie à l'océan Atlantique, le détroit de Gibraltar,
est très étroit. Il gêne donc le déplacement
de l'onde de marée. Et puis il ya une autre raison:
le plateau continental. Cette zone qui va
de la côte jusqu'au fond marin et qu'il descend
tout doucement... cette zone, qui est très large
dans l'océan Atlantique, est très étroite dans la
mer Méditerranée. Par conséquent, quand la mer baisse,
eh bien... l'eau ne peut pas
se retirer sur de longuesdistances.
C'est pour cette raison que les marées enmer Méditerranée
sont difficilement visibles.
Questions de Carole
qui va nous faire voyager:
Où ont lieu
les plus grandes marées au monde ?
Alors en Europe :
c'est dans la baie du Mont-Saint-Michel,
la mer peut se retirer jusqu'à 13 km.
Le marnage- c'est à dire la différence de hauteur d'eau
entre la marée basse et la marée haute -
peut atteindre13 m. C'est déjà énorme.
Mais les plus grandes
maréesdu monde ont lieu
au Canada, dans la baie de Fundy.
Là, le marnage peut atteindre 16 mètres de hauteur !
Ça fait rêver ou cauchemarder,
c'est comme on veut !
Voilàpour les marées,
la prochaine fois je répondrai
à vos questions sur la moutarde. N'hésitez
pas à les laisser en commentaire de cettevidéo.
À très bientôt sur les réseaux,
surla chaîne youtube et à la télévision !
Bye, bye :)